can you hear me now
good
any conflicts counselors um need to
declare at this point in time
no okay thank you
confirmation of the minutes and reports
and confirmation of the minutes the
ordinary meeting of council held on
tuesday 8 february some would like to
move that be seen as true and correct
councillor mctinelle thank you do i have
a signal for that councillor grant thank
you
is there any alteration required to that
set of minutes
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
uh confirmation of the minutes of the
community strategy committee held on
wednesday 16 february would somebody
like to move that be seen as true and
correct
councillor dixon thank you secondary
council mcphail thank you is there any
alteration required to that particular
set of minutes
it's not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried so
recommendations contained within that
report would somebody like to move that
they'd be
confirmed
councillor reed
seconded councillor macphail thank you
is there any discussion on those
recommendations councillor grant
yeah yes your worship item six
age-friendly business initiative
um
just a question on uh
on the following examples of what
businesses and things should do it's got
um doors easy to use push pull signs so
we we've got push-pull signs out the
front of our building yet it was cool
push-pull signs on our front doors
which was it was asked for last year at
some stage
and i don't believe they're there at the
moment
i can't answer that question no so
i think we should have yes
yeah that's right especially if this is
a council initiative absolutely thank
you
thanks counselor
uh any other anything else to be raised
councillor heisted
yeah thank you worship this item five
over eight years free swimming i think
it's a great initiative but just
wondering where
for the committee i wasn't at the
meeting where the age group of 80 was
selected from was consideration given 75
in terms of
making this
have a good impact or um where did he
come from
yeah
sorry
yeah yeah staff advice but i guess
generally across the country there
appears to be a trend of over 80 for
various
initiatives and we've got the driver's
license over 80
keeping the swimming at the same
same
age group but if you would like to alter
that then you know it's open for
discussion at this point
perhaps it could be part of the review
that occurs um the trial is running
rather than moving now so that's right
the free parking is 80 plus yep okay
thank you
okay anything further
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against emotions carried thank you
urgent light business is there any
urgent like business that needs to be
tabled today
not aware of any thank you
um
and item five goal district council
elections and the auditor order of
candidate names on voting documents
and there are three options as we
will know from the past
and
um
who's gonna lead this uh francis you're
gonna talk to this one okay as a deputy
returning officer
thank you welcome along
thank you um so this is all new for me
being deputy returning officer early
professor
um
currently we have the papers in
pseudorandom order if a decision isn't
made it automatically defaults to
alphabetical
your camp the candidate booklets are
automatically printed in alphabetical
order so there's no change to that
the recommendation is to go random order
which means every paper is slightly
different
um so there can't be any perceived
you know the first three on the list
always seem to be the ones that people
take if they're unsure
so
at the end of the day it's a decision
for
yourselves to consider what you'd like
on those papers
thank you okay
thank you francis my understanding is
random as every voting paper is is
different
so it's random where pseudorandom is
they're chosen at random but then each
paper is the same is that right that's
correct um pseudorandom they draw the
names out of a hat and that's the order
they go on every voting paper random as
every paper is slightly different yep
okay
right councillors um open full
discussion uh we
assumed to be the old person out or the
old council out last time around but
there's nothing to say that that's a bad
thing
we have been the odd person out on on a
number of occasions in the past
um
but certainly the majority of uh
of councils in south island and i think
it's probably true to say
across the country are completely random
now
council reed
thank you your worship
i just noticed in the report that
random it says requires specialised
software to set that up so i was
wondering if there was a cost to that
francis can you talk to that i believe
there is a slightly increased cost um
but i don't think it's an awful lot i
don't know how much i'm sorry okay thank
you
okay
counselor hosted
just a question on the booklet does that
remain an alphabet
it would have to be yeah i think it does
the candidate booklet remains in
alphabetical order irrespective of
the list of candidates on the voting
papers
so i'm happy to move the recommendation
that we
changed to random worship
thank you david segna for that
councillor bulger thank you
any discussion on that recommendation
if there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
right um
rethinking waste and this is a
discussion we've been having over uh
quite a lengthy period of time uh we
have a report today from our roading
asset manager who
is
looking at waste in this this particular
district so i'll hand over to um peter
just to talk us through what
um
what you'd like us to consider today
so
no
okay
so this is an opportunity to update
council on we have working group has got
with um this aspect of work
um just to update the council but also
to inform them of things that are
happening with government reforms or
initiatives that are coming up
so hopefully that does that since i've
written basically has been the
central government have come out with
the mfe got a
paper out of it moment force
for comment anyway and we've had uh
david parker the minister of um
of
of waste i suppose he's come over the
last couple of nights talking about um
um has his hit list i suppose for how
harry wants to actually dealt with from
a country
and i think the top ones there are to do
with a standardizing curbside collection
to do with organics and
also
the
plastics i think is right up there as
well so
if there's any questions on what i've
got written i do have a small
presentation i have uh nikki
boldwhiffers
who is heading some of the communication
with the public
so
okay um so
peter
is nikki going to talk to council now
sure
we do carry on we weren't able to
actually put a presentation up on the
screen at the same time as actually
having nikki so i've just got paper
copies if that's okay okay so you're
gonna hand those around
okay welcome along nikki um i'm not sure
whether you can hear me uh okay at the
moment but um now it's good to have you
at our council meeting today we've
been deliberating on this particular
issue for quite some time
and it would be really good to get
a sense of moving in the right direction
so we end up with the right
right result and since the last time we
we met and talked there has been quite a
bit of a change from government and
giving us some clear direction on where
they see the country going forward so
um look forward to what you've got to
share with us today and i'll pass that
over to you now we're in your hands
so there's there's three of us going to
just present here there's sonja
nikki myself just wanted a bit of
introduction to start with
okay rethinking waste so today we'll
just touch on why we're doing this how
are we going to achieve it and uh who's
going to be doing it
just a bit of a background jdc cordistry
council broke away from
southland
disability enterprises in 2020
we've been waiting for some central
government guidance on where we're going
with waste and recycling since that
point councilwood has also set up the
best focus group uh it talks to the
community but also the working party
which uh takes it back up to council
and community discussions are to be had
and we have just a wide event we've
engaged specialists actually help with
that work
so why we do why do we actually need to
rethink waste
that's probably the question that a lot
of people are going to be asking first
and foremost is what's wrong with what
we've got at the moment
we have one of our worst
uh waste dealers i suppose and uh oh
oecd as i think we were number 10 10
a bad list so um
we've got room to improve
also there's a large amount of resources
actually getting buried in our waste
um when we put it to landfill this is
sort of lost opportunity so we need to
sort of see it in that way
just to need to improve uh recycling and
some of um for the emissions side of
things too so there's some really good
reasons why we're actually going down
this
road
bring recycled systems up to a global
standard we are poor at that at the
moment
recycling has to be seen but it's not
the whole solution and just part of a
solution and as we've seen later it's
probably lower down on the list there's
other things that we need to be heading
out at first people are very passionate
about this whole topic so i think it's
actually a great opportunity to bring
the whole community on board and let
them be part of that discussion
um as you know the landfills are filling
up and some around the country are
actually falling apart so it's very
timely we have in this discussion our
landfill down south here isn't going to
last forever so we do need to be forward
thinking about what happens and how do
we
uh
turn this around
and obviously the increased government
levees is uh incentivizing change as
well it is going up um every couple of
months
so i was talking about david parker and
his atlasfear you see the breakdown of
our rupture it goes to to landfill
with paper plastic and organics being
right at the top there so that seemed to
be the focus especially with plastics
and the organics
dave park i think has
the commercial uses in his sights as
well as trying to actually turn that
round
but
he's got things like
returns the container return scheme
happening which sounds a very
a positive thing about getting plastic
bottles returned but it's 2025 so it's
going to be a few years until we see
that rolling out
so there's some statistics beer 25 of
our waste
at landfill is food
so
it's not just the mission as bad happens
when we have it in the landfill but it's
also
a waste of money this is costing us so
we need to be smart about how we how we
buy
food and how we uh how we turn it to
waste
once again this next page was just going
quickly over the tonnage you know 60 60
dollars per ton over
the next two years expected to rise but
it's going to be significant especially
when gorgeous street council turns about
to seven thousand
seven half thousand tonne of waste to to
landfill every year so sixty dollars on
each ton is
amounts up and that's on an existing fee
already so that's what it's rising
so i'll pass it over to sonia just to
run through some of the communications
and how we expect to put it out there to
the public
uh thank you peter in three year worship
um obviously running a community
engagement
project in this current climate presents
its challenges and we can't have too
many people together so we're very
fortunate that we've got some reasonably
well established and well um patronised
digital channels so there'll be a
probably a project page on let's talk
which is which is our main channel and
we can use various tools um i think
we're going to start with a tool with
people we're inviting people to tell us
their stories
about waste um how they use it how they
get rid of it maybe ideas they've got
we're also obviously going through
mainstream channels as well
using print media radio but it will be
very digital focused until such time as
we can have workshops and bring people
together
under the facilitation of nikki and
using her expertise to to generate those
conversations to create that awareness
not only on
how people you know deal with waste but
what options and maybe what ideas people
have even that they can bring and also
we're calling for people to be members
of a focus group so that's sort of the
conduit between the community and the
council's working party
so yeah we're using all the digital
channel all the digital channels and all
the communication channels in our
toolkit
and
yeah hopefully we'll be reaching all
sectors of our community which we can
you know do very well
and i'll just hand it over to nikki now
yeah look i'll introduce um nikki uh
bold from ahika an organisation in
dunedin who who deal with this sort of
amount of environmental and waste
matters she's an expert we have on board
but nicki might be able to tell a bit
more about herself before she uh
tells us about what's going to happen
good afternoon everybody
thank you very much for welcoming me
here
i do appreciate um being able to jump
into your council meeting to introduce
myself
and
to work
on this project so
as i said in my introduction i'm
actually from fair uh dales of yorkshire
but i've been in australia now for 20
years i work with ahika consulting i am
the
sustainability and voice recovery
specialist
and i've been working alongside bruce
middleton who you might have heard of
um
um
infrastructure and
what's going in and out of otago so that
was a really interesting piece of work
and i also worked closely with the
dunedin city council
and i've done the designer school of
five
inner city recycling packs with the
intention of trying to
reduce the contamination that goes into
recycling because it's a big issue and
putting them in the center of the city
was a challenge but we tried to do it in
a very creative
manner in order to try and ensure that
we could do something that was going to
be worthwhile in the future
and so
i'm going to be working with you guys
and i'm actually really excited about
this because i would love to talk
rubbish and this is really up my alley
and the fact that you guys are taking
the steps and literally trying to
address ways
so the fact that you've opened up the
conversation
is absolutely fantastic and the fact
that government's trying to do the same
thing they're trying to rethink
the whole system as well and you guys
are ahead of the curve by having this
already underway so
i i just want to say well done
and so yeah the whole point of why i'm
here is to help with the information and
getting that information out to the
public and opening up that discussion
and really trying to educate
your community about
what we mean by rethinking ways to
consider there's a big topic and it's um
we are going to open a few candid
recycling that it isn't the only
solution and it really isn't because
unfortunately we have a lot of different
types of plastics and in new zealand we
can only recycle three very specific
types of plastic
which does mean that recycling has been
a little bit inefficient for a very long
time but with government government's
new um consultation document they are
talking about trying to standardize that
which really helps in order to try and
get the conversation opening about what
and you can see that there's so many
ideas about what we can do first which
is refusing and reducing reusing
repairing and repurposing our waste
before we get to the idea of rotting it
which is composting especially with our
food race or recycling it or then taking
it to a landfill and disposing or
burning it so the way hierarchy is an
incredibly important tool and this
waste hierarchy has come from the
ministry for environment so
it is something that is supported by the
government so we're talking the same
conversation that the government is
and different ways that we can try and
start to start the
anyone who has any questions for finicky
before
we break away
i think this is uh
you just just before we get onto
questions this is very much the
beginning of uh
of a of a project for us and and and i
don't well i'm not sure what the council
expects from this but i think that this
is going to take us a little bit of time
we have to
connect very strongly with our community
on this one
and i know that there are a number of
different views
from those people who just want to put
stuff on the ground to those people who
want to do the recycling and reduce the
waste as much as possible so
we need to strike some balance along the
way but we also need to understand
where the the challenges are and
certainly that that challenge that
nikki's presented us around
the plastics and what can be recycled
and what can't um
that that's a major issue in itself and
we can't deal with that one ourselves
that really does need to be dealt with
by government
um but
that will be making up a lot of our
waste those
plastics that can't be recycled at this
point in time but
we have a number of hands going up for
questions so i'll um
counsel bulger
um it's a can of worms isn't it
and i notice that can of worms is
producing 12 of their methane uh
nikki i'm pleased to hear you're you're
a recycling or you're a waste specialist
i want to know what central government
they're going to do
you know on one hand they're imposing
levees they're giving instruction
they're giving
a direction they want us to follow but
they don't seem to be doing anything to
help with the recycling side of things
there's no facilities to
uh that they could fund or they could
promote for us to send the stuff to
but you know i i do find it quite
on the nose almost insulting
uh that they would suggest to go and
increase the waste levy to 60 a ton
when they should be part of the solution
over to you please
what a central government doing to help
us with a recycling facility or at least
somewhere to burn this stuff to generate
energy
so the waste levy that is increasing
goes into a fund which is available for
entities to apply to if they've got
waste reduction strategies and a plan
and then that money goes specifically
into being able to
help
implement
those plans so some of those could be
around building new facilities
[Music]
[Music]
that's not the right solution um there
is a better trial going on in northland
with composting everything as much as
possible
and creating better materials that we
can actually compost properly back down
again but all of this comes down to
businesses wanting to
put their effort and
their money into it so
there is a wastewater yes it's
increasing the wastewater goes to
support ideas to try and reduce these
things um
i can't answer
your question regarding why are they not
doing things because in my opinion i
think they're trying to help um and i
think what they're doing now with the
constant consultation document regarding
recycling is to actually try and
standardize recycling so that we
actually remove the materials out of the
streams that we can't recycle there's
also stewardship being
is going to um
really help reduce the types of
vegetables coming into the country but
we just can't deal with
we're not a big enough country to be
able to build some of these materials
that it's just too costly for companies
to set up and create a manufacturing
plan to deal with the likes of tetrapak
for example um
and tray it's free
and
to take those pieces
you just need massive massive plants to
do that and in new zealand we just don't
have the people in consumption
so
if i could just jump in there and
i understand that the challenge that the
councillors uh council bulge is placing
um before us
and why is it all our fault why is it
why why are we the ones that have to
come up with the answer i think and
councillor you may not have seen there's
a link in your emails from um i did i
did read it this afternoon did you watch
it
so i did i uh
i gritted my teeth and watched it
good on you um so i think there's the um
the criticism that
government haven't been doing anything
and they've been seen asleep at the
wheel uh is probably fair up until this
point but now we're actually starting to
get a little bit of direction and that's
that's what we need because we've been
floundering
literally floundering and trying to work
out what is the best solution
um but you had a question
not so much a question look thank you
for your answer nikki and peter thanks
for the report
i can't i can't be too critical because
this is a really difficult
um
naughty problem i i think what i'm
trying to
point out to those people who are
watching us live streaming
council has very little room to move and
no facility and no tools to apply to
this we're willing to we want to we've
put a lot of a lot of discussion and
i've been
part of that discussion over a ten-year
period
so for those people who are rape powers
on the community you know ask the
perpetual question what's council doing
council's got no room to move and i
believe the the the
uh part of that
answer
lies with central government and nikki
you've made the point that uh air scale
to recyclers is not sufficient for a
large industry to see to set up overseas
they won't take care of recyclables now
so we are in an awkward
awkward situation
the suggestion that we're going to be
leaving 60 a ton i think is an absolute
crime
please quote me somebody by by central
government you know
you damned if you do and you're damned
if you don't anyway i've made my point
and i'll
i'll switch the mic off now you worship
thank you counselor
make just one more point on that
yeah absolutely okay
have to face the um that we can't just
keep buying more and more stuff into new
zealand and
sticking it as a whole
um
the wasteland is putting pressure on
everybody to stop doing that and that's
um at least the money is going into a
place where we can kind of find better
solutions but you're right we've been
floundering for a long time because the
problem has been getting worse we get
more and more clever technologies that
bring more and more materials that we
just can't deal with um we want these
things all these consumer items we want
all of this wonderful technology but we
just haven't sorted out how to deal with
it at the other end and we're now
literally swimming in
all of the stuff that we've been
we've been bringing in we have to stop
doing that and that's what the wasteland
is about so i know it's painful but this
problem is
and this is
and i think the next part of this
journey and correct me if i'm wrong
peter is that we'll get connected a lot
with the community and really understand
what they want us to do
i believe that what we've done in the
past has been really good we had an
incredibly
popular and efficient recycling system
in place which the community bought into
in
leaps and bounds
unfortunately things changed in terms of
costs and
the ability to recycle so now we've got
to look
long term at what the sustainable option
is for the future not just in the next
two or three years but for going forward
and
and i think we do need before we
make any decisions on this particular
situation to engage very strongly and
but there is quite a lot of feedback
coming in to me as mayor i know and just
just this afternoon as i picked up on
getting the stuff to come down to the
meeting picked up off of modesto a
letter that's come from um
local kindergarten
mere hicks we're wondering um if the
gore district council will start taking
our recycling we're worried about where
the rubbish is going
one of our teachers takes air recycling
to the south and district council
but we'd love to be able to do it
in the gore district so look
right from
those
people that are preschool
through to geriatrics are starting to
think about what
and where their waste should be going so
we behold them to um to take it very
seriously
other questions or comments glennis
thank you worship um i agree with what
councillor bulger was saying but i also
think we do have a tool and our tool is
to reduce waste rather than just have a
mindset about recycling we need to think
about what we're purchasing and how we
can reduce the waste
council mcfarland
it's obviously been part of the um
through your worship and um in response
to some of council bulger's comments um
been part of this process and sort of
ended up as part of this working group
and with peter and
getting getting through some of these
commentary
i think uh yes councillor bulger has
correct
recycling and the various things that
central government have
pushing down it is correct to have the
have the same we can we can
bash the table and thump the floor and
throw our arms in the head in the air
but we still have to have a starting
point and i think the starting point
rests within the community to actually
start looking at what we're doing
we're generating it comes out of us we
accept it we buy it and uh we have this
expectation well particularly the
uh
the the people within the ghoul area
that these rubbish students just get
taken away and there is some recycling
or something magic happens to them and
sadly it doesn't a lot of it just goes
over tip face costs us dollars um and
that's the end result
uh if we look at the hierarchy with
the waste hierarchy that has been put in
the presentation this afternoon
recycling is way down you know it's
about number three from the bottom
there's about seven different items
above that we need to go through and
start thinking about and i'm not saying
the council
can do it there's people out in the
community
that have to take responsibility and
actually have to stand up and say
you know what am i going to do for my
part and whether it's the kindergartens
saying we go to our
other other councils
i know that we've asked the question
through nikki as well that
what are they actually recycling
where is the recycling going to it would
be an interesting question which will be
part of our
part of our workshop as well
a lot of people are saying they're
recycling things but i'm not quite sure
where it's ending up i think you'll
probably find it sitting around the
countryside and in piles um trying to
work it out so
yeah we've got an interesting road ahead
of us um and i'm glad that we've got
nikki on board and
just this initial work we've done and
we've got some support there and just
just get into it um the incinerator yep
that would be great
but i don't think we've got the uh i
don't think we've got the capability or
the capacity for that at the moment
and the other thing is i think we've
positioned ourselves
probably a wee bit better because we've
now got central government saying that
they they're going to require this well
we should put us out of the position to
try and get some of that funding if it's
criminal for them to take the money from
us well we want to try and get some of
that money back and put it into our
schemes to see if we can um do something
in our local community i know we're
little but we always say we're nimble we
should be able to move um move well so
good luck to
us thank you council macphail
[Music]
any other questions or comments from
councillors around recycling i think
this is really an update this is just a
staging point along the way to let
council know and let the community know
that we are
embarking on this particular project and
it will come back to council
again for
decisions along
along the course of it
but if there's nothing further
would somebody like to move the receipt
of the report thank you council macphail
and seconded
councillor reed thank you all those in
favor please say aye
case the motion is carried thank you
nikki for
presenting this afternoon and thank you
for being part of the
of the group that are embarking on this
particular task
talk again i'm sure
thank you very much
we'll move on then to uh item seven
and uh we have a report here regarding
amendments to rate remission policy and
definition of separately and used or
used or inhabited part of a rating unit
and i think jamie's put this report
together steve do you want to make any
comment before i pass over to jamie or
lorna
yes just briefly worship it's designed
to
streamline
our rates remission process so that
there is no need to
go to the council and the staff can
administer the policy
so that rate payers that are presented
with a particular issue can
get
pretty much instantaneous relief by way
of a staff decision to enable the rating
problem they have to be taken care of
that's really the purpose of this
particular
item but uh mr calliam can talk a bit
more detail about that
so
jamie or lynnae yeah jamie it's yours
i think this is your first appearance at
a council meeting isn't it yes your
worship it is it's good to have you here
yep thank you
um so through your worship um i'd like
to address this report in two parts if i
may just to make it uh simpler for me to
explain as i'm sure you've noticed i've
got an odd accent so just to
keep things as clear as possible
so the first part of this is about the
remission of penalties uh one of the
things that we have in our remissions of
penalties policy is five points and none
of the points in the current policy
addresses the fact that we should have
the ability to remove penalties where it
facilitates the arrangement of
repayments of arrears
and the
implementation of a direct debit
um or or that sort of ilk
generally penalties shouldn't be seen as
an income stream for council it's merely
a mechanism to
assist council in recovery of the rates
that are actually charged rather than an
extra income stream so rather than using
it purely as a disincentive the ability
to remit penalties when we get the
behavior that is good payment behavior
um as an incentive to repay rates and
get accounts back up to days so that's
really the first part
which is the the remission of penalties
the second part is a bit more technical
and it was drawn to my attention by one
of the rating staff
is that there is quite an onerous um
task
regarding the administration of
remissions for
what what we would term as mixed use
commercial properties that is where
someone's actually running a small
business
from within
their household
so
examples of that are very small dairies
being run from a room essentially that's
at the front of the house
or a hairdressing operation that's been
run from a room within the house or a
converted garage within those
to be distinct i'm looking at the
current policy and for me because i'm
new i've only been here three months
i'm trying to get the flavor of what
council's intention was with
the policy and before it was done as a
remission policy which i've actually got
on page 23 if you look at towards the
bottom there
um that's that mixed residential
commercial use properties where the
owner or operator resides on the
property and the key statement there is
a commercial activity operating from
within the residential dwelling so
what we've got is we've got some
circumstances where there's a
significant development at the front of
the building
often a fully contained
business with a commercial kitchen etc
i don't think the objective of this
policy should be applying to those
properties but it should be to
the relatively small number i think
there's about four properties that
really meet the test of someone running
a business from their home
um
so basically that does have a small
financial implication in that
with those properties there would be a
difference between rating them as
residential
and reaching those commercial of around
about 800
a year
and what this does is this gives them a
remission of around about 400 of that
but that's treating them as if half the
property is being run as a business
where in actual fact it's actually a
very small footprint and the question is
whether or not it's equitable and given
the additional workload that staff have
to go through we have to re-value
we have to get qv to value the
properties two separate properties
create two separate rates assessments
which we then have to administer twice
the amount and then we have to apply
remissions on both of those as well
so for the for the four
properties in question it becomes quite
an onerous task every year first have to
go through and the question is whether
or not that
gain of 400 is worth it or whether we
should just rate them as
a dwelling therefore the way around that
is just to change our definition of
separately user and have it apart to say
that
if someone is running a small business
like a hairdresser's from their front
room we won't necessarily try and rate
that portion's commercial we'll just
rate it as a house and move on
so it's again it's it's really about
what is council's appetite in that space
um
thank you thank you jamie and thank you
for the thought that you've put into
this i recall
when that the current policy was put in
place and there was a lot of a lot of
debate um and and council was quite
determined to go down that particular
track but
you know i think you might put the
points you make makes sense to me
uh particularly given the small number
of uh rating units that are involved but
i'm keen to hear from councillors
councillor grant
thanks your worship thanks jamie um
yeah good report uh question
so if you weren't going to write a small
business as the commercial part of it
would that business such as a small
hairdresser or a small physiotherapist
room or whatever it is tucked on the
side of a building would that still
require resource consent
that would depend on the district plan
which i'm not aware of um so it would be
down as to whether or not it was a
permitted activity under the district
plan in that zone
um and whether it would require a
separate so that would be a planner
question not something that i know much
about
okay thank you
okay other questions or comments
of jamie
um councillor
dixon
um thank you your worship i just have a
question in the background it's the
bullet point too
remission of rates will be applied where
the rate pays enters into a direct debit
arrangement
that is sufficient to keep the rates
count up today what does that actually
mean because the remission means that
the rates are remitted
is is that the penalty or is that the
actual rate that you're talking about
through your worship that's in respect
of the penalty where someone enters into
a direct debit for weekly monthly or
fortnightly repayments one of the
particularities about that because we
spread the rates evenly across the year
is that by the due date which is usually
two months after the rates
rating year
they've only paid two-thirds of that
installment
which means that the third of it that
would be subject to a penalty if we
didn't have a policy to make sure that
we remit that penalty and allow the even
spread of direct damage across it so
that's just a technical point that
allows us to remit the penalties i
should have rates penalties in there
right yes which would make it clear and
also i have another question
um if you
if you put two titles
of land together
and have one rate
if you
sell one of those titles now you're
liable for the rates right up to the end
of june which
so if you sold a property say the 1st of
july
then you could you are up to pay a whole
year's rates to the end of june i'm
wondering
where does that fit into this and are
people aware of that
that's
that's due to in part to the current way
in which we process what we call section
20 properties that is properties where
multiple titles are used as a single
rating unit
it is actually possible that you
you do not need to pay them right up to
the end of the rating here if it's two
existing
titles
if there is an actual subdivision
happening
um
then the rates do need to be cleared if
it's a true subdivision but if it's just
selling a part that was treated as that
there are two
separate rates assessments that can
actually be brought into bear so the new
owners can actually pay the remainder of
the year's rates
which is a slightly different situation
to the situation we're considering now
so
we're trying to get the two of
yes no it's not um what
lawyers are telling people sorry
okay council but um heist
you thank you russia and your council
dixon just in response to that normally
the solicitors apportion that through
the settlement statement take that into
account so
they sorted out between the two parties
from my experience so
um i guess
i guess i just find myself looking at
the complexity of what we put in place
in the debate that went round that and i
realize there's an issue we need to
address but i don't know if we've
necessarily got the balanced
view on first of all what is their
philosophy as a council around these
businesses operating from home fairness
to the cbd operators that are paying
rent and rates and are you know eric's
buy vendors that turn up in town not
paying rates and and could obviously
have a view on
on the people operating businesses from
home
and and also the growth in this like the
the with with covert there's a new world
coming on us called working from home um
and i think as a council we should just
pause and reflect on that if we have
time um i'd be quite interested in just
having that as as a debate on
where do we see it as a council we we
put in place what's there for for very
good reasons of the council at this time
i realize it creates a whole lot of
drama for four properties here but
that's that's the now
um and is there another way in terms of
in terms of um
giving some fairness to the to the cbt
right far so
that's my feedback anyway but a good
report jamie and no criticism of what
you've done um just
think that uh yeah there could be just a
workshop or a just a brief discussion
around that
some good points you made and i guess in
in my view the the critical point of my
mind anyway is the the definition of
small
small business and i'd like to get a bit
of a sense around what that actually
means and looks like councilman fail
just through your worship just general
comment regarding um what council
heisted stating because how many
businesses we did we actually say we
were
looking at
four
it's more than that at the moment there
are other ones receiving it but they
don't meet the test because what's
happened is that over the years
subsequently they've extended and
the watts may have started out operating
out of the front room has become in some
cases a development that has got a
higher value than the residential
portion plus a commercial kitchen plus
multiple rooms
because
i don't know whether through um with tax
records and things like that i dare say
there's probably a lot more people that
have got businesses that have been
claimed for working from home so
um and whether they've got businesses
that are actually there
um
you know it's one of those uh
one of those cash 22 situations i don't
know whether we contain
other information from other sources or
do we just rely on those that put
through
like applying for the uh
for the remission
okay
is there any other councillors that want
to make a
appoint here um i think that the point
that councillor uh high stage raid is a
good one maybe it's time just to
reflect in the council have a
workshop with jamie and the finance
staff and just
see if we can get to a point where we
all feel comfortable that we've got us
the most
as much information as we need to make a
clear-cut decision
is
that
what councils would like to see happen
at this point in time
okay
maybe
okay so
my attention at this point in time is
i would welcome
a recommendation in two parts
um
a part that deals with penalties
and a part that deals with separately
inhabited
units and will take those
at separate times
somebody like to move
along those lines
moved uh councillor grant
and so you're um
we'll take
we go to the first one first which is
allowing staff to be able to
penalties
so you're moving on that
yes
yep
okay
so we have a motion that
um
so the recommendations on the bottom of
page 24
um be the motion that we're considering
at this point in time
there any counsellors are all counselors
comfortable with that or would you like
something else
if there's not uh councillor
dixon thank you worship just a query
before we um recommend that
it's regarding the proportion of land
that's in the ghoul district or the
southam district
and the
rates would be remitted if
there was no um houses on the gall
district
part of that land
but i'm just wondering if
80 of it was in the ghoul district and
20 was in the south in the district with
a dwelling on the
south and district
part
does that mean there'll be no rates
paid on the 80
it's just
clarification on there
yeah so um jamie you're steve do you
want to make a comment on that um it's
really into boundaries i'm just not sure
whether that
council bulger
some like you yeah
yeah that's right
yeah absolutely
remove my emotions i'm not going to
support that one i'm actually in
agreement with uh
councillor heist and we should actually
have some sort of discussion before we
actually do this so there's two parts
there is a discussion on the second part
i'll put it back in there
i might have been away for a week or so
thank god for that
i'll carry on i'll let you carry on you
okay so i'm going to put the motion um
which relates to um remission of
penalties and it's the recommendation
largely on the bottom of page 24.
um
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried for the
separate part of discussion around um
separately inhabited uh and rated units
would somebody like to move that we can
be in a workshop to just discuss all the
implications that this might
have for the council
council bold uh councillor heisted uh
councillor reed seconded
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors and thank you jamie
for the work you've done
right um we'll move on then to item
eight which is um policy on disposal of
land and buildings
and we have a report here from the chief
executive
talk us through this one
steve
thanks your worship this is uh the
intention is to try and regularly review
our policies and the sale of land
one is
quite old and was very much tailored
towards compliance with the
public works act
1981
but
given the
reflection of time since then it's
appropriate that we take on board um
other
philosophies the council has since
adopted so this policy talks about
utilizing the to sale to retire debt
it talks about a competitive process
for when we want to sell land and
through through a selection of agents
and also
acknowledges the role of ewe in
consultation with the previous policy
was silent on
and more importantly when it comes to
strategic
or unique property it gives the council
the ability to consider
um
the
means by which and and the parties to
whom we may sell the land under a
different criteria than just purely
price but that's the proposal that's
purely based on council discretion and
there is a range of factors included in
the new policy including such things as
for example the proposed use of the land
uh it may well be relevant and that
could be relevant to
an urban or
a very small rural environment
where
use
and
possibly the type of purchaser involved
may
prompt the council to step outside a
pure economic lens that may apply to the
matter in question so really you wish it
was just a
trying to
encapsulate what we think is a modern
approach to
divesting property
it hasn't to a degree been informed by
the process that we're using at the
moment with the sale of mata red
sections where
for example the agent that's working
with us on that
was selected through a competitive
process
where
each each company was invited to put
forth the credentials and through a
measured analysis and evaluation
first national were given the knot so
but certainly it's just a draft and the
start of 10 for the council to consider
and
make comment
okay thank you steve so the item is open
for discussion and or recommendation
you're moving council hosted
all right question that's okay um
um just through you to to the chief
executive um so valuation registered
values reports
proved to tend to be
behind the market in terms of what's
going on they're not future focused
they're very much the past so is that
just applying the public works act
criteria where registered valuation
must be taken into consideration for
former owners or is that policy that we
can work with
um
through your worship intention was and i
must check the wording that it would be
either or either
a
real estate agents assessment of value
or a registered valuation
sometimes what will happen is that
you will get a
if it's if it's a direct negotiation
under the public works out and it's a
very awkward piece of land
you probably need a valuer to say look
this is what it's worth
but certainly
absolutely
when it comes to a market estimation of
value
when the market's moving
you want you're wanting really a real
estate agent who's working in that
market and know what's coming ahead and
again mata ridge was a classic example
of that where
the registered valuation versus the
uh the values
estimated by the real estate agent and
ultimately attained through the
marketing process were considerably
different
okay so i guess under 5.2 it says it the
equivalent to the current market
valuation from a registered valuer so
it's quite
particular that it comes from a
registered value so whether
that can be tweaked
if appropriate
5.2.2
this is from a registered valuer right
um
i think that yes that's actually
a slight oversight because the intention
certainly was to have
the ability to choose a real estate
agent or registered valuer so
my suggestion there that we would amend
that too
that it would be either
account equivalent to market valuation
assessed either via a real estate agent
or a registered valuer
the choice of which is at the discretion
of the council
okay thank you
good point
any other comments or questions of chief
executive on this one
so with that change
um
council high said are you prepared to
move that
notion
i am except i just see it at the bottom
of page 37 and 38. the old policy sits
there that is the typo like we've
already had the policy put in front of
us
and the last sentence says this policy
was adopted by the gorsuch council on 15
march 22 just the relevance of having
the existing policy
oh i think it's a bit of a
a word
the they start i don't think it belongs
there the slow chart should be the end
of the document no sorry yes it is it's
only for reference for the council so
they can see what we had previously
versus what we're making yes
that will go out
okay
what's that point of clarification
you're moving that council to high state
and secretary councillor grant thank you
any further discussion does not put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
all right on to item nine um and
proposed uh covered 19 short term rates
deferral policy a report that's come
from the chief executive and
jamie so i'm not sure who's going to
leave this one
to do
thanks your worship this is um
really at the it it's jamie's suggestion
and really a resurrection of our
policy to be put in place very quickly
when covert 19 first emerged and
the country went into lockdown
that policy had a short-term shelf life
deliberately
and then we all thought we were turning
to some sentence of normality
now with omicron
alive and kicking it was felt
appropriate
to
resurrect this policy for a short period
of time to enable the council to offer
assistance to those
ratepayers that are feeling the pinch uh
clearly and with that in mind there has
been
um some signals that have come to us via
elected members and others in the
community that some businesses are
finding it
tough
at the moment in terms of the business
environment
therefore
we felt you would like at least the
opportunity to
revisit your 2020 work
and perhaps institute
this policy which as the staff had
reported
while it wasn't taken up in a wholesale
manner it was
welcome relief for those handful of
businesses in 2020 that were
experiencing tough and uncertain times
thank you have you got anything to add
to that jamie no great i think i think
it's pretty straightforward council
bulger
great job secondary council reed thank
you councillor heisted you had a
question
i didn't i think i raised it when we put
the last mechanism in place and that was
the proof of hardship i really felt and
i think the council agreed at the time
not entirely that
someone coming to council wanting rates
relief bearing minuses for a short
period it's going through tough times
and to put
an onerous prove it
on them to me a bridge too far if
someone's prepared to come to council
and say i need some help i think we
should help them it's not for a long
term it's for a short term
and i think if we get taken for a ride
by a couple of people that's okay we
still they still rate past their own
property
um so the proof part to me is just a bit
tough and maybe i'm
a little bit generous but that's how i
feel okay look that's a good point you
raise and i just asked the chief
executive
perhaps you could relate some of the
experiences of the
the last time through how much of an
issue was that
through worship i could recall when we
debated last time and there was talk
about making it
user friendly and not putting barriers
in place and
generally the approach to the staff has
been
look you as council heists have said
you've made the effort to come and
contact us you need some relief and
generally it was given because at the
end of the day it's deferral
not a cancellation
but if if the whirling needs to be
changed we're happy to do that too
because certainly the culture of the
council
is uh i don't recall
and and perhaps
laurnae or maybe jamie might be able to
correct me but i don't recall
an application being turned down last
time they're pretty much fronted and
were given that relief they sort
and that's just been confirmed by the
staff
okay so um
lorna that was the case sometime jamie
yeah
great
councillor reed thank you worship um not
i'm just speaking now about the ordinary
rate payers not the people in business
um
but obviously it's very tough for them
at the moment i mean the town's
pretty pretty quiet so but perhaps it's
time through our channels
once again to remind um people about the
rate's remission
because for some of them they will you
know it will be a big a big help
absolutely
um
so we have a motion uh on the table
um and does the motion is the
recommendation
there's no change to that a councillor
hosted
can i just ask councillors to look at
page 48 and look at
residential rate payers and what owners
must
be
to qualify they must have evidence of
loss of employment
payment from an employer under a
government support package or qualify
for a mortgage holiday
that's our policy
hmm
yeah okay
yeah yeah you worship i agree with
council heisted this that's pretty
at the moment that can send someone over
the edge yeah with all this
there's a lot of things backing up at
the moment and there's a lot of people
out there feeling it so if they come
with cap in hand as you've said steve
they come with cap and hands
um it's
it is a great relief it's not a we're
not going to um
get rid of the rates yeah it's just a
deferral payment so
um
i would seriously
look at that as well because uh
here uh staff have to apply the policy
and you can't just basically go
willingly
okay so i'm i'm open for an amendment uh
a wording amendment council bulger i'm
not going to put an amendment but i
notice um
the qualification is one of the three
and the third one is a 30 reduction in
revenue since the 20th of march 2020 now
this person who would be wanting to
avail of themselves of this policy i
would expect has had a reduction in
their revenue or income so
i don't see that as being particularly
honest the other two yes might be a bit
difficult but that's the one that i
think the most people would use i think
council bulge uh council heisted i can
determine the coulee council bulge
tonight i'm sorry um
it's fine
um i think the the
the clause you were referring to was
residential rate pass was it yeah the
the reference that council bulge is
making is commercial business so
i look i i don't think we can solve it i
think i think if we give the chief
executive and and the um
the management account direction in
terms of make it make it work
because as possible as the council grant
said staff have to adhere to our
policies that we set and otherwise
ordinary risks are going to have you
know more reports from auditors
and we've got enough things through your
worship you could if you wish put a
catch-all at the end
so point four or any other circumstances
that
um
may deem to cause undue hardship and
that could cover a multitude of issues
i'll make that amendment has that we'll
add that to the motion
okay
okay so um
the amendment has been um i'm sorry that
the motion has been slightly amended
unless there's any uh objection to that
i'm going to put that motion
so all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
certainly the the intent of this policy
is to make it as easy as possible for
ratepayers who are having a tough time
to
ease that burden somewhat
um right we'll move on then to item 10
and a review of the gore district
council keeping of animals policy and
bees bylaw 2016.
and looks like we need a working party
uh to uh
our hearings panel sorry
to
to work our way through this one so
is there any
volunteers for that councillor bulger
so we've got councillor dixon's name is
there any other names that um any
councillors would like to be part of
this
bylaw review
counselor nick grant thank you
and
anybody else
councilman how are you very quiet
good honey thank you
so we have volunteers from um council
dixon
council make to now and councillor grant
somebody had to move that recommendation
thank you uh
lots of volunteers uh council grant
councillor phillips all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried
right
um we'll move on to item 11 the cap
management
and control
subcommittee
and we have a report from the chief
executive
which emanates from
a request some time ago do you want to
talk to this one
steve
yeah thanks to worship it was uh not
necessarily the
the highest priority in my workload but
uh certainly that the issue generated a
good deal of publicity when it first
arose last november
and i have given some thought as to how
we could attack all the issue
one of the key things about this of
course is the identification of what is
the problem and i think that's the most
important aspect of this working party's
work
because if you don't define the problem
you probably won't come up with the
right solution
um
certainly the hakaneranga have expressed
keen interest and they've they can
actually point to a number of
initiatives that have been
deployed
throughout southland and further north
to address the issue of particularly
the environmental risk of cats
in native bush
and the proposal is to also you utilize
the skills and experience of mr ian
maxwell
um who is now wanaka based a former
auckland council executive who looked
after all the parks and reserves in
auckland city
and has had some experience about coming
up with initiatives to deal with the
problem of of cats and their threat to
native bird life
so this is
just a starter for 10 in terms of the
terms of reference the compilation of
the working party
was
again just my idea feel free to contract
expand as you see fit
and in regard to
where this may lead us to um don't know
but i think it's a case of i suspect
there's probably going to be a case of
both
some slight regulation and some
incentive based initiative to try and
address the problems that
the working party party identifies
yeah i think the point you make um first
steve is is the real one what is the
problem we're dealing with
and once we've worked that out then i
think a lot will fall into place council
grant
thank you worship um
when i i
brought this to the table in november it
was a question i've asked about
i wasn't actually concerned about
prowling [ __ ] it was all only about
cats the number of
number of cats
that
someone is allowed to keep
sorry see you must have seen you
uh
the problem is
we there was an issue in the macarthur
in the cargo there were
someone had over 34 cats in their
residence and that was my issue my issue
is where's the by-law here
so i didn't really look at
the problem of cats in the hokkanui but
it has been brought up
whether or not this council wants to
take that that far
but my interest was
um
the volume of cats that someone is
allowed to keep because uh
yeah this this is a very hot topic and
um there are a lot of cat lovers in in
gore
um i i used to have my oldest cat passed
away a couple years ago she was 21 and a
half years old
and uh
you know it's it's one of these things
that it's very dear to some people's
hearts we're not about to
the idea was not to go and say right
you're not allowed more than two cats or
three cats it's the volume of cats that
um
someone could without a bile or without
something in there someone could uh
decide
to have a calorie and or
or breed cats and you could have 28 of
them in a back of a yard so this is
where i was coming from i'm not i'm not
i'm not sure whether we should be going
um further than getting into the whole
canoei area of of cats
but you know the roonanga have have uh
talked about it so
yeah and i guess that that will really
be the task of the working party just to
establish what the problem is and and
what the potential uh solutions to any
problem that may not be a problem
and that's um that's yet to be
determined
i think the
the problem in the rural area is quite
different to the problem in the urban
area um and the same solutions are not
going to apply in in both
so look it's open
for discussion counsellors
and
if we're going to take this any further
then we need to appoint
a working party
and the suggestion that's been made is
there's two rural councillors and two
urban councillors
to the subcommittee which will be
matched by
people from hakone
as well
so open four suggestions
i think um
given the council of grants raised the
subject then probably be appropriate for
him to be part of the working party if
that's
suitable with council grant if i'm
available yes
i can
i seem to remember counselor dixon
mentioning some interest as well thank
you
can i just say worship too that i don't
think it's really um
my issue was about feral cats and i know
there's an awful lot of feral cats in
town and in the country as well and they
do a lot of damage and
cause a lot of disease to our
pet cats too so i guess that the first
point of um
well the first task the working party
will
have and we'll set it two or three times
already is establish what the problem is
and then work towards a solution if
indeed there is need for a solution
so we've got
two urban councillors
looking for a couple of rural
councillors
um
so corey i can't quite hear what you're
saying
would counselor davis be available
so we've we've got to
she's she's district what
yeah so i guess the suggestion is too
urban too rural
yeah that's right okay um councillor
davis
council davis are you interested in
being part of this group
she's not there
i think that's the answer
is
council davis um
just we're discussing the cats um
management and control subcommittee and
just wondered if you are interested in
being part of that working party
that's fine okay
um you worship
i'd probably volunteer if that's all
right yep you can the um the reason why
i'm doing this because matera has
already established
formal communication with the
fever holmes and also the president of
matera who looks after
spading the the jets the community board
has
has had an initiative in in uh helping
funding that program in matera
so
i think just to keep the board on the
straight and narrow
um
i'd like to be on part of that great
thank you
i'm sure i've seen a cat at your house
okay look we're going around in circles
here a wee bit so we've got three
councillors that are volunteered
yep thank you councillor bulger
we have four councillors
um but somebody like to move uh the
recommendation
and the appointment of those councillors
councillor nick grant and councilman
mcphail thank you is there any further
discussion there's not i'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
i think counselors that brings us to the
end of the open
uh section of the agenda
uh and i'll now move that the public be
excluded from the following parts of the
proceedings of this meeting namely the
items listed below
items containing
confirmation of minutes of previous
meetings